hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es kein koch und kein
backrezept denn heute gibt es mal wieder
ein schwangerschaftsabbruch die jetzt
ganz oft danach gefragt war nicht
endlich mal wieder eins mache und ich
weiß es ist ein bug und koch kanal aber
ich werde immer oft nach der
schwangerschaft gefragt und auch so habe
ich viele fragen so rund um unser leben
deswegen trägt da auch gerne ab und zu
mal ein video aber ich lag diese videos
dann immer gerne so außerhalb meiner
üblichen upload tag also mittwoch
freitag sonntag hoch und falls euch dass
sich interessiert könnt ihr einfach
wieder abschalten
auf ihrer geht es heute um eine
schwangerschaft und zwar bin ich jetzt
aktuell in der 34 woche und ich wäre
doch echt immer runder
und mir geht es im moment ganz gut ich
habe jetzt nur noch etwas sechs wochen
bis zum entbindungstermin und es ist
echt nicht mehr lange und es ging auch
unfassbar schnell vor allem waren wir ja
auch noch vor kurzem im urlaub da ging
es dann auch nochmals schneller und ich
habe jetzt halt auch ganz viele fragen
von euch gesammelt und möchte ich
einfach jetzt in dem video beantworten
eine der häufigsten fragen war natürlich
sally wie fleiß jetzt schon zugenommen
ich habe jetzt mittlerweile also
wirklich ungefähr 74 einhalb kilo
das heißt ich habe ungefähr 14,5 kilo
zugenommen und fühle mich im moment auch
noch ganz gut also es ist noch nicht
schwer sondern es fällt mir im moment
noch relativ leicht sag ich jetzt mal
also so vom laufen her und vom stehen er
ist zwar schon so dass ich jetzt nicht
mehr so lange stehen kann weil ich dann
rückenschmerzen bekomme und ich merke
auch schon im liegen dass es halt
ungemütlich wird weil sie entweder links
oder rechts liegen muss und nachts
versuche ich halt immer links zu legen
weil dann die versorgung des babys
besser ist habe ich halt gelesen und
deswegen tut mir meistens hat so die
linke seite immer weh aber ich wechsle
dann immer kurz nach rechts und dann
wieder nach links und dann fasst es auf
jeden fall ganz gut genauso mira hält
jetzt auch schon denn das maßband ihn
ich habe jetzt auch ein aktuelles in
aktuellen bauchumfang von das waren eben
moment ich glaube ein meter 14 und 15
das heißt um im vergleich zum letzten
mal habe ich jetzt sieben zentimeter
bauchumfang dazu gewonnen und
das baby entwickelt sich auch ganz gut
und wiegt jetzt auch mittlerweile schon
2400 gramm und ist etwa 44 zentimeter
groß und so miraß bauchumfang sagen wir
jetzt auch gleich moment sein
bauchumfang 62 das geht dann gar mit 90
60 90 hallo geht's noch warten noch mal
60 hat sie 60 passt auch perfekt
entwickelt
der vater starb und jetzt kommen wir
einfach weiterhin zu euren franken wir
machen das jetzt einfach so der bbu hat
stellt mir die fragen und ich beantworte
dann kann es einfach
ok schieß los also einer der häufigsten
fragen war der name des kindes genau
also dem ich mich jetzt halt auch
verraten
und zwar durfte die samira ihre namens
wünsche äußern und hat schon seit
längerem einen namen im kopf
und wie soll deine schwester heißen da
als die kleine wird er heißen
der name hat uns beide noch sehr gut
gefallen vor allem deswegen weil halt
die aussprache sehr einfach ist die
schreibweise ist so einfach also wir
werden die türkische schreibweise nehmen
das heißt es wird dann hat michaela
ausgesprochen sondern ella und mir war
es eben ganz wichtig dass man den namen
einfach nicht irgendwie anders
ausspricht als er geschrieben wird und
dass es hat ein einfacher name ist bei
uns ist nämlich zum beispiel so der
morath kann ja zum beispiel auch nicht
meinen namen aussprechen richtig das
sagt ja immer also ich weiß eigentlich
sarah und da ist nicht mit ja immer
salia und deswegen sag ich ja was
eigentlich kaputt was der unterschied
widerwillig egal ob ali h mit h und
sachsen sahen ja ja ja auf jeden fall
hat seine mama zum beispiel auch das
problem sie kann zum beispiel amiras
nahmen auch nicht aussprechen also
samira meine eltern sagen ja auch samira
mit dem türkischen r und
ich glaube dass man sagt immer sie mir
oder so und deswegen hat sich gewünscht
dass wir dieses mal leichteren namen
nehmen wobei wir für uns also wer selber
entschieden wie wir unser kind nehmen
weil es sich ja oft so dass bei der
namensgebung hat jeder irgendwelche
vorschläge und irgendwelche wünsche und
ich finde es sollte einfach dass das
eltern also die eltern sollten es
einfach selber entscheiden
immerhin ist er unser kind und seiner
schwester und deswegen haben wir so
zusammen ja das entschieden ich jetzt
gerne genannt wie meine mutter nein oder
das wollte meine mutter meine mutter wo
ja deine mutter wollte dass bei uns in
der familie also bei auf meiner seite
der familie es ganz normal dass wir das
kind nach den eltern benennt so ist bei
uns mein vater heißt zum beispiel morath
ich heiß morath wenn ich meinen sohn
bekommen soll wahrscheinlich deswegen
keine haben so lang wie es mir so
bekommen und den will ich den rat ja als
auch seine mama hat sich das gewünscht
aber wie gesagt machen wir das nicht und
ich bin noch am überlegen ob ich noch
einen zweiten namen nehmen weil ich
finds halt immer ganz schön dass namen
hat auch eine schöne bedeutung haben
samira heißt zum beispiel prinzessin und
ich habe herausgefunden dass die zweite
bedeutung aber auch die unterhalterin
ist was ehrlich gesagt perfekt
zusammengepasst weil es hier unterhält
immer jeden gelb und die prinzessin bist
du auch und ja und das ist ein
türkischer name gibt es aber auch in
anderen ländern und da heißt da bestimmt
auch irgendwie als der transport von
daniela hat eine andere bedeutung und
auf jeden fall im türkischen ist das
seine farbe und zwar hat der [ __ ] hat
zum beispiel seine augenfarbe dass ich
so dieses braun grün soja und deswegen
hätte ich eigentlich noch gerne
zweitnamen dazu gehabt und mir hat der
name meliá ganz gut gefallen das war ein
vorschlag von einer
zuschauerin und das habe ich in den
kommentaren gelesen und melia heißt die
schöne deswegen eventuell noch der
zweitname auto hatte schnitzer
begeistert von den zwei mädchen und ein
name einen einnahmen bereich ja da das
immer noch einmal überlegen ja wenn es
zwei namen wird ich meistens ein waldorf
schüler murat komm mach weiter mit der
frage wie lange drehst du noch videos
wirst du weniger drehen
also im moment drehen wir eigentlich
schon noch regelmäßig unsere videos ich
gucke dass ich immer mittwochs freitags
und sonntags meine videos hochladen und
es klappt ja auch im moment ganz gut und
wenn wir mal einen tag nicht so gut geht
dann drehen wir auch nix oder hand
früher auf und ich versuche jetzt gerade
so ein bisschen vor zu produzieren weil
ich glaube nicht dass ich jetzt
irgendwie noch in fünf wochen wenn ich
kurz vorm entbindungstermin steht dann
noch drehen kann weil ich denke wir
schweben nehmen dann einfach auch zu so
mit dem gewicht und es wird
wahrscheinlich anstrengender
deswegen möchte ich einfach so eine
gewisse zeit überbrücken können
und schaut einfach mal vielleicht bis
ende keine ahnung als ich kann solche
eigentlich sagen jetzt sagen im moment
geht es mir gut ich kann gut drehen und
es klappt alles ganz gut und dann
schauen wir einfach mal treu es gibt ja
heute treu weil das nicht möglich ist
die tun dann müssen die letzten drei
monaten liegen oder soja oder noch
länger ja und noch länger also ich heute
hast du alles geklappt
okay wir haben dann die letzte frage
babyparty bh shower party genau da haben
mich wieder gefragt machst du eine baby
shower party und ja wir haben eine
gemacht als er jeweils auch gerade am
wochenende
und zwar was ist eine baby shower party
vielleicht hören dass manche zum ersten
mal
woran hat er gefragt kegel shower party
also so das deutsche wort schauer aber
das wort kommt aus dem englischen also
baby dusche party kommt daher und zwar
der name kommt daher dass hat die ma
master mit geschenken überhäuft werden
aber im also von da kommt hat er
wieso macht man so eine party ich finde
das immer ganz cool weil man hat einfach
nach der geburt vielleicht die erste
zeit nicht so wirklich die zeit um sich
mit seinen freunden zu treffen und auch
im jahr wird auch nicht die los
übermüdet und möchte vielleicht sich
einfach mal ausschlafen und hat einfach
ja braucht die zeit für sich fürs baby
und einfach so die neue
familienkonstellation und deswegen
trifft man sich dann ganz gerne vor der
geburt da hatten wir ja noch etwas mehr
zeit vor allem wenn sie im mutterschutz
dann ist und zu hause ist dann kann man
sich noch mal mit seinen freundinnen und
freunden treffen und sich wissen
austauschen und vor allem war es jetzt
auch bei uns so also es gibt die eine
möglichkeit dass die freundinnen das so
planen das thema mal gar nichts
mitbekommt und das praktisch eine
überraschungsparty wird oder so wie bei
uns jetzt ich habe den termin vorgegeben
weil ich einfach im moment nicht so
viele freie termine hatte wegen der
messe in wien usw
und dann habe ich alte in termin
vorgegeben und habe gesagt wenn ich
jetzt gerne dabei hätte und dann hat
halt meine beste freundin die nadja das
für mich organisiert und geplant und hat
es eben einfach veranstaltet und das war
jetzt am samstag also den vorgang ja und
ich würde sagen wir schauen wir jetzt
einfach mal rein und ich zeige euch ein
paar ausschnitte
ja wer die szene kennt der weiß dass
gutes essen egal wann man bei der city
auftaucht nie fehlen darf jetzt haben
wir uns heute mal dazu entschlossen als
ihre gäste in teil dazu beizutragen dass
es ihr gut geht und die sally hat jetzt
im moment etwas mehr hunger als sonst
ich habe das ganze natürlich nicht
alleine gemacht und ich habe mit der
tatkräftige unterstützung gesucht was
man übrigens immer machen sollte wenn
man eine baby party organisiert von ganz
vielen ganz lieben menschen denen die
sally auch alle am herzen liegt und die
möchte ich euch jetzt vorstellen wie
versprochen jetzt hier all die lieben
menschen versammelt die sally eine ganz
besondere freude machen wollten und
heute hier zu ihrer baby party gekommen
sind haben wir ganz viele sachen
zusammen vorbereitet und uns natürlich
abgesprochen zu zeiten von whatsapp ist
natürlich auch immer sehr gut um sich
miteinander absprechen zu können
zum teil haben wir uns ja heute auch das
erste mal kennengelernt also eine baby
party ist auch immer ganz schön und mal
so zu sehen wie den sich der
freundeskreis zusammensetzt und wir
freuen uns dass gleich darauf uns ans
essen zu machen und ich hab halt so
kleine geschenke kostet und zwar einfach
an meine freundinnen und man danke zu
sagen und da habe ich mir so ein kleines
döschen besorgt bis zehnfach süßes
eingetrieben und der dosenöffner den
fang ich ganz cool weil der hat
praktisch ist es ist kein staubfänger
oder so sondern man kann auch nix damit
etwas anfangen
ein bonbon
zeigt euch jetzt erstmalig war nämlich
gestern bei der babybauch bemalung bei
meiner freundin lisa und ich hab da ein
kleines video und das zeige ich euch
jetzt kurz wenn ihr wollt
das
jetzt ab der die paar schritte gesehen
und mich hatten jetzt auch einige noch
gefragt was ich noch an ausstattung
brauche und da kann ich jetzt anknüpfen
und zwar habe ich ja jetzt auf meiner
baby shower party auch ein paar sachen
bekommen wie zum beispiel diesen dieses
laufgitter und so weiter oder diese
babytrage für den morath und für mich
natürlich wurde das baby drin liegt und
jetzt fehlen mir wirklich ganz wenige
sachen nur noch also mein kindersitz
habe ich jetzt schon bestellt den
autositz
ich werde mir noch einen hochstuhl
kaufen weil wir haben ja auch schon
einen für samira einen stocke hochstuhl
und den hochschulen habe ich damals für
sanierer neu gekauft und jetzt möchte
ich einfach noch mal so einen weil das
hat echt richtig praktisch da kann das
kind wirklich ab säuglingsalter bis ich
nach 15 jahren drauf sitzen und da
schaue ich mich jetzt aber eigentlich
sagt nach einem gebrauchten um weil die
stühle die sind ja echt für die kriegt
man jetzt kaputt und die sind so
qualitativ hochwertig dass man auch
wirklich da die gebrauchten stühle
kaufen kann
das heißt wenn er zum beispiel in meiner
umgebung wohnt und einen stopp der
studilux werden wollt können nämlich
gerne an schreibung einfach eine e-mail
schreiben ich kaufe den dann euch ja
weil diese noch richtig teuer
ja das sind auch richtig teuer aber ich
finde das ist eine investition die lohnt
sich zwar deutlich sagt wir sind 32 euro
ich finde so extrem teuer aber ich finde
dass ich diese chance und gegenstand
oder möbelstück da geht es um die
sicherheit die stühle die kippen halt
nicht egal was das kind darin macht und
aber ich zeige euch das einfach mal in
meinem ausstattungs video also das
machen meint net das würde den rahmen
sprengen
ja matschies weiter los ja ja ich habe
ja kein hochschule als kind ja du bist
wahrscheinlich den kopf nein wir sind so
arm gewesen sie hat nicht meinen tisch
und er sich dann offen wurde gegessen
so ist es bei uns gab es mehrheitlich
ist kein spaß wir haben nur so kleine
fische am boden gehabt das waren so
schäffler
die die türken und durch kenntnis hatte
in der türkei noch beim ein paar beim
dorf da hilft man sich da am boden und
hat dann so eine riesengroße tischdecke
oder aber die schützen das
gesprächsthema
wenn wir uns streiten das schreiben uns
ein meisten um den preis dieser dinge
ich finde der kino sieht zwar auch
richtig teuer der autos sitzen ja ja wir
sind halt auch sondern
das ist für mich so ein sicherheits
gegenstand wo ich sagen muss da muss man
investieren und die habe ich frage mich
dann immer hat denke ich denke mir immer
meine jugend zurück und ich hatte so was
nicht und haben mit papiertüte gelegt
und noch schaffen dazwischen dass ich
nicht rum rutsche in den kofferraum dass
ich und ich habe auch überleben ja aber
es gibt halt auflagen und zum glück gibt
es die ja auch also diese autos sind ja
auch so wenn die zu alt sind und dann
gibt es eben wieder neuauflagen dann
darf man ja die alten sitze nicht mehr
nehmen muss die neuen nehmen und ich
finde es auch ganz gut so dass die immer
geprüft sind vor allem wenn man zum
beispiel auch mal ein autounfall hatte
also gott bewahre
aber da muss man auch sein auto sitzt
immer einschicken noch mal prüfen lassen
und kann den halt dann mitarbeiter
benutzen und das finde ich halt auch
ganz gut denn ich finde sicherheit geht
war aber mit ja
bevor nur das finanzielle was auf einen
zukommt bei einem kind sollte man nicht
unterschätzen ja aber deswegen hat man
ja auch familie und man kann sich ja da
das nachholen und auch gebraucht holen
okay die nächste frage wirst du stillen
wenn ja wie lange
ja ich habe schon vor als familie habe
ich auch gestellt ich musste sie nur
leider schon nach sechs monaten ungefähr
abstimmen weil es einfach damals zu
stressig für mich war und zwar habe ich
ja studiert ich war ja schon zehn tage
nach entbindung wieder an der uni und
habt weiter studiert hat sie dann immer
am anfang mit dabei
und irgendwann ging das aber nicht mehr
weil ich musste ja immer nach karlsruhe
fahren und zu und dann wollte ich sie
halt nicht ständig mit nehmen ja und
dann habe ich irgendwann abstellen
müssen nach sechs monaten
und wenn es jetzt klappt und ich denke
es klappt ganz gut dann werde ich
natürlich meine jetzige tochter auch
still und wie lange weiß ich nicht auf
jeden fall mindestens ein halbes jahr
und dann einfach mal schauen wollen
jedoch ein drittes kind ja also
definitiv definitiv wir machen so lange
bis es ein junge wird dann kriegst
wahrscheinlich nie um einen krieg an
ihren jungen okay aber hier war viele
kinder noch milch hatte ich denke wenn
jetzt alles gut läuft seit dem zweiten
kinder hätte ich schon noch gerne
eintritt ist rot und fit ist
ich sage immer wenn ich immer geld dann
richtig ok also worauf freust du dich am
meisten baby füttern zimmer einrichten
klamotten kaufen da wieder was dazu
sagen muss man immer einen grund haben
zum kaufen also ich finde einfach ich
freue mich als kind
ich freue mich einen vertrag keine
gründe musste kaufen also ich würde
jetzt das finde ich auch als ich freue
mich am meisten auf die kuschel stunden
so dass man wie das ein bisschen zeit
für sich hat und zeit mit dem baby und
mit samira kuscheln und ja das ist
eigentlich so dass wo ich mich am
meisten drauf ist mein essen koche ich
jeden tag und klamotten kaufen ich habe
von sanierer noch ganz viel als ich
glaube nicht dass ich überhaupt was
kaufen muss ja ich freue mich auf die
gemeinsame zeit und das war halt eine
größere familie werden
ja was ist für dich am schönsten in der
schwangerschaft das schönste für mich
ist also eigentlich eine schwangerschaft
so wir haben gestern im rat darüber
jetzt wo ich gerade schwanger bin und
kugelrund bin kann ich mir ehrlich
gesagt nicht mehr vorstellen wie das war
ohne babybauch als ich weiß nicht mehr
wie es war mit einem flachen bauch und
andersrum ist aber genauso als ich noch
nicht schwanger war konnte ich mir nicht
mehr vorstellen wie es war mit bauch und
das schönste für mich ist eigentlich im
moment das ich halte mein baby im bauch
ab und ich spüre auch immer ganz fleißig
die dritte und so weiter und ich habe
das baby im moment noch für mich alleine
und ja das hat schön man kann immer so
einfach schlafrhythmus verfolgen und ich
habe zum beispiel in der spieluhr
geschenkt bekommen auf der baby shower
party und wenn ich jetzt abspielt dann
reagiert sie da auch immer mit
bewegungen drauf und samira kuschelt
immer ganz gerne mit mir zur zeit und
streichelt meinen bauch und spricht mit
ihrer schwester genau so und das finde
ich eigentlich so am schönsten und ich
genieße es wirklich
also auch wenn man sich irgendwann dann
sagt okay es können so langsam kommt das
baby finde es trotzdem immer schön
nächste frage hast du vor eine pause
nach der geburt einzulegen
ja also ich denke gezwungenermaßen werde
ich sowieso eine pause einlegen
man weiß ja nie wie es einem nach der
geburt geht wie gesagt ich habe mir eben
schon ein wenig beisammen da war ich
zehn tage nach geburt schon wieder an
der uni und jetzt einfach mal schauen
wie es funktioniert ich habe jetzt dann
nicht nur ein kind sondern zwei ich muss
gucken wie es mir geht wie es dem baby
geht aber auf jeden fall startet wird
doch sobald mir langweilig wird und
sobald ich einfach wieder kräftemäßig
kann wenn ich gut ausgeschlafen bin und
wenn es uns beiden gut geht dann hätte
ich auf jeden fall wieder loslegen mit
den videos ich bin hat auch kein mensch
der einfach rum sitzen kann und
irgendwie also ich muss dann sowieso was
machen und mir fehlt es ja dann auch
also märz jetzt auch im urlaub gefehlt
das video drehen und deswegen denke ich
schon dass es dann relativ zügig wieder
losgeht freut sich samira ja so freut
sich total jetzt sind zwar leider
korrekt aber sie freut sich auf ihr
geschwisterchen und ich hoffe das bleibt
auch so
also im moment sieht es ganz gut aus ok
hat das yoga geholfen
ja das problem ist ich habe euch ja
gesagt ich gehe zum yoga und ich wollte
ich auch unbedingt gehen aber ich habe
es leider nicht geschafft aber ich weiß
von einer freundin sie geht zum beispiel
regelmäßig ein mal die woche und bei ihr
hilft wirklich ganz gut ich weiter und
dafür bei der krankengymnastik zweimal
die woche und hab mich da behandeln
lassen
und das hat mir auch sehr gut geholfen
als ich würde euch auf jeden fall
empfehlen was zu machen und ich mache ja
auch weiterhin die übungen die ich zum
beispiel mit der ana gemacht habt und
das hilft mir auch ganz gut also somit
den rückenbeschwerden und so weiter
wurde wirklich viel besser zieht ihr um
ihn ein neues haus ist die wohnung
vielleicht zu klein
ja das war es dass die stimme zu hoch ja
wir wurden ja es sieht zwar immer alles
so groß aus hier
es ist auch eine großzügige wohnungen
aber wir haben halt nur ein schlafzimmer
und kinderzimmer und den offenen wohn
essbereich und es wird so sein das baby
wird am anfang sowieso bei mir im zimmer
mit schlafen und umziehen wollen wir
jetzt eigentlich noch nicht die wohnung
ist uns zwar zu klein aber jetzt nicht
nur wegen dem baby sondern allgemein
weil ich halt immer auch die videos
drehen und ich habe einfach so viel
equipment die ganzen kameras und lichter
und so weiter steht halt immer alles rum
ich hab kein extra raum wo ich das
irgendwie verstehen kann
sondern habe da die gästetoilette dafür
missbraucht und habe alles drin stehen
und ja wie gesagt am anfang ist wie bei
mir mit dem zimmer später wird sich dann
einfach erstmal ein zimmer mit samira
teilen und wir wissen einfach nur nicht
wann wir mal umziehen oder bauen ob wir
umziehen genau wir wollen ja irgendwann
auch was bauen was eigenes und wird dann
einfach so die zukunft zeigen was auf
uns zukommt der bahn hört sich immer so
extrem anlagen bei uns sind die
grundstückspreise noch normal wir sind
auf dem land also nicht vergleichen mit
in münchen wo man haus eine halbe
millionen millionen oder eineinhalb
millionen kostet bei uns jedes opel ist
der traum ein eigenes haus
das ist ein riesen garten also mit
garten auf jeden fall wir wohnen jetzt
im dritten stockwerk und wir haben zwar
eine großzügige terrasse oder balkon
aber du kannst halt das am ihrer auch
nicht allein spielen lassen weil im
dritten stock ich finde es halt immer
ein bisschen gefährlich und mein traum
dass man einfach ein haus mit garten zu
haben und hühnern und ziegen natürlich
auch ein ziel ich sehe da gehen wir die
band vor gefragt
ok wirst du das baby in den videos
integrieren zeigst du es oder zeigst du
es nicht
ja also das ist sowas bei emirates zum
beispiel damals so ich habe sie am
anfang ja nie gezeigt macht sie immer
nur gehört aber irgendwann war es
einfach nicht mehr zu vermeiden weil sie
sich immer mit ins bild gedrängt hat und
immer wenn ich halt gebacken habe oder
gekocht habe ich sie halt immer mit dazu
gekommen und so hat sich das er dann mit
ihr entwickelt das sie dann praktisch so
bestandteil meiner videos wurde nicht
weil ich sie jetzt unbedingt mit rein
zwingen wollte sondern es war einfach so
die mama war in der küche hat gekocht
und sehr dass sonst auch immer mit mir
gekocht und mir geholfen
also hat sie dann was inhalt auch bei
den videos mit dabei und ich denke jetzt
bei der tochter wird es genauso sein es
wird sich einfach nicht vermeiden lassen
die wir dann auch irgendwann kommen sich
hinstellen und sagen wir mal ich will
jetzt auch mal rühren und dann ist sie
hat auch mit dabei wir wollen ja ich bin
ich wieder weg dann kommt sie wieder
dazu wenn sie lust hat und ich kann
meine kinder nicht abgeben oder
irgendwie ins zimmer einsperren nur
damit ich es videos drehen kann
also das ist ja es ist bei uns so ich
doch was und film deshalb einfach kurz
mit für euch und das ist einfach aus dem
alltag heraus und deswegen kurzes gut
kurz ich gut weil das nicht immer so
leicht an es ist nicht einfach manchmal
beim motiv 1042 das war manchmal und
deswegen kann ich da meine kinder nicht
einfach irgendwo abgeben oder ins zimmer
einsperren also die sind halt dann die
wohl hier und spiele hier und wenn sie
nicht gerade im kindergarten ist oder in
der bei freunden da nicht sehr alt mit
dabei und ich denke so wie es bei
unserer zweiten tochter genauso okay
nächste frage höre ich mit dem babybauch
wohl oder fühlst du dich zu dick also
ich finde mich nicht so dick nur
manchmal wenn ich mich im bett unterwegs
dann fühle ich mich leicht zu dick weil
es ein bisschen schwer fällt aber so
finde es ganz schön ich schiebe ich dann
auch angeheuert den wahl auf die andere
ich hab mich auch meine freude also auto
rausgeschoben weil ich nicht hoch
gewinnen na ja auf jeden fall nicht so
dick fühle ich mich nett ich weiß ja
dass der bauch danach wieder weggeht
hoffe ich zumindest ganz schnell
ich wünschte ich könnte das gleiche
behaupten ja wünscht muss sagen wird das
ist ein bisschen die frage wird samira
bei der geburt dabei sein dann ist
alarmiert über die frage also in samira
peter geburt dabei wäre müsste ich ja
wahrscheinlich die nächsten zehn jahre
wie eine therapie im therapieplatz
besorge ich hab eine seelsorge geborene
kinder können natürlich nett war der
geburt mit dabei sein weißer miras
geburt war der monat mit dabei und meine
mama und dieses mal wird auch der morath
mit dabei sein und ich weiß nicht ob ich
eine zweite person möchte er doch lieber
bei meiner mama muss hat nach samira
gucken die muss ich dann abgeben
samira kann auf keinen fall mit ins
krankenhaus man weiß auch nie wie lange
geht so eine geburt und das wäre für ein
kind also es wäre ein traum wenn ein
kind eine geburt miterlebt von daher
jedoch sei aber auch nicht wieder leben
ok also auf keinen fall okay
nächste frage hast du komische
schwangerschafts gelöste ja also was ist
essen betrifft habe ich eigentlich gar
keine gelüste so großartig ich es zum
beispiel fast nichts süßes also kaum
süßwaren wobei ich das vorher auch nicht
so gegessen habe weil wir viel kuchen
und torten backt so die ganze woche über
der hat auch nicht also zumindest ich
hatte dann halt nie wirklich lust auf
schokolade oder so entschuldigung das
war s baby und jetzt ist auch immer noch
so dass ich halt keine lust auf
süßigkeiten oder so habe ich es relativ
viel gemüse und obst aber ich habe eine
komische angewohnheit und zwar habe ich
es in der türkei auch ganz verstärkt
gemerkt ich spreche aus silly ich mich
halt total gern börse sich anhört aber
immer wenn wir tanken waren oder das
tanken find ich richtig war total gerne
zur diesel und benzin als ich wills
danet riechen weil ich immer denke ist
es schädlich oder neulich hat jemand was
geklebt und meine cousine hat sich neben
mit den nägel lackiert und ich stehe
daneben dran an dem auch das recht so
gutes recht so gut aber ich hoffe das
geht wieder weg
also es gibt die erst scheint ja auch
frauen zu geben dass stand nämlich mal
in meiner app drinnen die wollen sie
etwas trinken
also was ist so abgelöscht und darauf
haben was wirklich krank ist aber also
ich es halt gern aber ich versuche es
nicht zu riechen weil ich denke
nagellack abgase und kleber sind nicht
so wirklich gesund war
das ist die einzige komische
angewohnheit ja nächste frage meint für
es wird anstrengend mit zwei kinder zu
drehen ja ich denke schon also wenn man
ein kind hat dann geht es ja noch kann
man das noch gut händeln mit zwei
kindern ist schon so man muss es eine
versorgung dann noch das andere kind
versorgen dann auch sich selber ich
denke schon dass es anstrengend da wird
aber ich denke es kann auch alles regeln
also ich sehe es auch bei meiner
freundin die hat auch zwei kinder und
sie sagt du die beschäftigen sich dann
zusammen also irgendwann nicht am anfang
aber irgendwann beschäftigen sie sich
und ich denke es klappt ganz gut also ja
ich könnte jetzt noch nicht sagen bin ja
auch noch da von dem abgesehen
ja wobei ich dann eigentlich drei kinder
habe weil morath will auch beschäftigt
werden
eine gute note gut ab für
alleinerziehende frauen jährlich ganze
ja also das ist ja bei mir wirklich so
der rat unterstützt mich sehr meine
eltern sind für mich da und wenn samira
morgens an im kindergarten ich habe ich
ja dann im prinzip auch erstmal nur ein
kind zu hause und ich denke das kann man
ganz gut steuern
aber wirklich hut ab vor
alleinerziehende also das stelle ich mir
richtig anstrengend vor
und da haben wir noch die oma ja also
wir haben wirklich ganz ganz groß wie
ein gutes netzwerk ich habe schon meine
eltern ich habe meine freunde meine
geschwister und meine cousinen und die
sind wirklich alle immer für uns da und
es springt immer jemand einen wenn wir
mal jemanden brauchen und von daher
klappt das ist ja auch immer alles ganz
und deshalb auch nicht jeder also
wirklich alles nackt weil das thema es
gebe nur laub wie ist es den fliegen
zellen wie geh jetz auch die kate wird
an ihnen
du fliegst genau ich fühle mich im auto
genau weil das fliegen ja zu teuer ist
und ich ja auf jeden transportieren ich
muss ja auch viel transportieren ja also
es hat mich wirklich viele gefragt wie
es mit dem fliegen ihr start noch
fliegen und ich habe jetzt manchmal eine
ganz normale schwangerschaft mir geht es
ganz gut ich habe kaum
schwangerschaftsbeschwerden und deswegen
kann man nach dem dritten monat auch
wirklich durchgehend eigentlich fliegen
also muss ja was heißt durchgehend ich
wieder nur zweimal in die türkei
geflogen jetzt lege ich einfach noch
nach wien und ich lasse natürlich vorher
immer so ich lasse mich immer vom arzt
durchchecken und jetzt ist also ich bin
zwar jetzt sechs wochen vor
entbindungstermin und das kind wiegt er
wie gesagt 2400 gramm honig gut
entwickelt und trotzdem habe ich
natürlich nach kontrollieren lassen
und er hat gemeint es ist jetzt nicht so
dass ich irgendwie eine frühgeburt
riesen frühgeburt risiko habt also darf
ich trotzdem noch fliegen und man
braucht man einfach bei den
fluggesellschaften zum beispiel bei
lufthansa erwartet so besser express war
das so
und ich denke auch bei den anderen das
kann man online nachlesen wenn man zum
beispiel lufthansa schwangerschaft
eingibt dann kann man sehen bis sowie
viele und schwangerschaftswoche immer
noch fliegen darf also bis wann euch die
fluggesellschaft eben auch mitnimmt und
bei lufthansa was ist zum beispiel so
darf man bis zur 36
woche fliegen das heißt bis vier wochen
vor entbindungstermin und deswegen kann
ich jetzt auch noch nach wien fliegen
weil ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen nach
wien mit dem auto zu fahren acht stunden
das wäre mir zu anstrengend also das
hätte ich nicht hingekriegt weil erstens
mal drückt grad
mein kind meine blase flach und ich
müsste wahrscheinlich nach jeder stunde
im stopp machen und außerdem ist das
ganze sitzen dann einfach zu anstrengend
und da ist halt für mich einfacher und
vor allem viel gemütlicher einfach eine
stunde zu fliegen und dann vielleicht
noch eine halbe stunde zu fahren und
deswegen darf man das aber man braucht
ab der 28 wochen attest vom arzt dass
man eben fliegen darf das kein
frühgeburt risiko besteht und es müsste
einfach mit eurem arzt absprechen und
vor allem nach der fluggesellschaft
gucken weil damals bei samira war es zum
beispiel so als ich schwanger war waren
wir auch im urlaub das war unser erster
urlaub und da war ich glaube 31 woche
neben der 32 und man durfte aber nur bis
zu 31 pflegen oder hatte ich mega
problem zurück fliegen weil dem ich
nicht mitnehmen wollten und dann war ich
halt am schalter da haben die gesagt ich
muss jetzt wieder nach antalya zurück
fahren ins krankenhaus und mir das so
eine bescheinigung holen und dann zimmer
einfach am flughafen zu dem arzt und ich
glaube ich habe dem 20 lehrer gegeben
und er hat meine bescheinigung gegeben
weil mir ging es sehr guten ich hatte
kein frühgeburt risiko aber das war
einfach total das chaos damals und bevor
ihr jetzt als schwangere fliegt sollte
auf jeden fall mit dem arzt besprechen
und vorher eben noch mit der
fluggesellschaft und dann ist wirklich
kein problem und auch nicht anstrengend
also ich habe auch keine probleme mit
thrombose oder so ich habe zwar
thrombosestrümpfe mir besorgt aber ich
hatte ehrlich gesagt zu hause vergessen
und aber es war wirklich kein problem
auch in die türkei zu fliegen war alles
gut ist ein ganz ganz spezielles thema
willst du einen kaiserschnitt
oder nicht also ich will keinen
kaiserschnitt aber ich glaube es hat
sich im letzten video schon angesprochen
dass auch meine erste geburt eine
normale geburt war und dass ich auch
jetzt wieder der normale geburt möchte
und hoffe dass auch alles gut läuft und
ich keinen kaiserschnitt braucht aber so
wie sie jetzt im moment ist das kind
liegt mir kopf unten und also ich würd
ich bin halt so die so eine person ich
würde jetzt kein wunsch kaiserschnitt
oder so machen ich habe aber auch eine
freundin die hat zwei kinder die sind
zwar schon älter sie hatte zwei mal
wunschkaiserschnitt und war auch super
zufrieden damit mainz wäre jetzt nett
weil für mich ist es hat einen eingriff
der für mich jetzt nicht sein muss weil
ich denke dass kann man auch ohne
operation durchstehen vor allem finde
ich halt so die risiken zu groß also da
kann ja alles mögliche passieren
natürlich wenn man jetzt bei der geburt
gratis entstehende notsituation
notkaiserschnitt her da kann man ja
nichts anderes machen
aber für mich ist nur normal geburt
einfach so dass für mich für mich
perfekt aber es muss natürlich jede frau
selber entscheiden
das vg 99 prozent sei ja in der türkei
fast so da haben wir dann also die
nachbarin von meiner mama
die hat jetzt zum zweiten mal entbunden
und hatte auch kaiserschnitt zweimal
grund kaiserschnitt aber da ist hat auch
so dfc raten die das also die sagen auf
jeden fall jahr machen kaiserschnitt
weil der normale geburt weil viel zu
risikoreich und keine ahnung aber ich
denke dass ich einfach so
dabei sind die mediziner stadt irgendwie
ganz anders also die haben eine ganz
andere denkweise und es werden da
wirklich alle frauen zu einem
kaiserschnitt eigentlich irgendwie fast
gezwungen schon und es wird gar nicht
über die normale geburt gesprochen
also sie hat dann noch zu mir gesagt
genau das war nämlich so die jetzt
gefragt wann eben das baby kommt da habe
ich seither am 21 oktober wer weiß
vielleicht früher vielleicht später sagt
sie wie machst du 'ne nummer zwei wieder
normal geburt und habe ich sagte ja xavi
hatte schon kaiserschnitt sagt sie ja
und dann wir beide gleichzeitig ob das
würde ich nie machen also für sie war
das total selbstverständlich dieser
kaiserschnitt für mich ganz
selbstverständlich die normale geburt
und das sind einfach zwei ganz
verschiedene denkweisen gewesen
da muss jeder für sich entscheiden wenn
jemanden wunschkaiserschnitt möchte hat
es sich das ja wahrscheinlich auch gut
überlegt aber ich fühle mich muss sagen
ich möchte vor allem habe ich mich nach
sanierers geburt wirklich ganz schnell
wieder wohlgefühlt ohne schmerzen und ja
war richtig fit was hast du nach der
messe in wien vor also die messe das
habe ich jetzt auch meinem arzt
versprochen dass die messe in wien so
meine letzte große aktion sein wird weil
wenn ich aus wien wieder zurück bin bin
ich ja schon in der 5
verstehen der 36 woche habe ich noch
vier wochen bis zum entbindungstermin
und ich muss mich jetzt einfach ein
bisschen schonen ich darf auch kein
gepäck tragen können einkäufer tragen
hallo fragt genau kann ich auch nicht
kommen weil es einfach als ich denke da
würde ich wahrscheinlich unterwegs das
kind kriegen bei der autofahrt und
deswegen ich muss mich jetzt nach der
messe in wien etwas schonen
ich werde zwar weiterhin meine videos
drehen wenn alles gut klappt aber nach
wien möchte ich halt auch so ein
bisschen jetzt die zeit nutzen um mich
vorzubereiten
ich muss meine klinik tasche noch packen
das sind auch in sachen da muss ich dann
nachts immer daran denken und denkt oh
gott eine klinik tasche ist noch nicht
gepackt und ich habe noch keine
babyklamotten gewaschen und ich habe
noch kein bett aufgebaut
also wir müssen das netz bauen und
deswegen also ich hab dann murat im
urlaub auch schon ganz verrückt gemacht
habe sagt gott wenn wir zurück sein
bestes und das alles machen sagt er
jetzt noch mal langsam erst mal die
messe und dann das baby war dann haben
ja die vier wochen noch und können uns
da einfach zeit lassen
wie gesagt habe ich kein separates
kinderzimmer das baby schläft ja doch
noch bei uns aber ich muss einfach so
den kleiderschrank bisserl herrichten
und wäsche waschen und samira schläft ja
auch wir uns die schlafen alle bei uns
im zimmer und dann kommt sein achtes zu
uns aber ich muss sagen ich genieße es
auch zur zeit
das im zimmer außerdem liegt dann
manchmal wiederholt ohne das mache ich
dann einfach zu viel wäre unsere video
unser bett kommt dagegen trainiert sind
ja das wollte ich eigentlich nie das
samira hat dann bei uns im zimmer
schläft aber ich muss sagen ich genieß
das alter zeit so das kuscheln und dann
finde ich das so schön und ich meine
irgendwann macht es ja nicht mehr
deswegen warum nicht solange sie
nebenzimmer einschlägt und dann zu uns
kommt ist alles okay so das war jetzt
die letzte frage ich habe jetzt geht es
noch um die welt sehen wie ja da war
noch eine frage was gibt's auf der messe
in wien jetzt diesen freitag fängt sie
an diesem freitag das historische 11
genau mein elfter ob 11 12 13
und genau das sind wir dann auf der
messe in wien dem radweg sagt fed dem
auto hier nicht fliegen und auf jeden
fall wird der main stand wieder
aufgebaut und ich mache dem messer auch
ehrlich gesagt nur euch zuliebe weil
meine österreichischen zuschauer also
ich hab ja sehr treuer zuschauer und er
schreibt mir immer ganz viel und ich
möchte jetzt einfach auch mal nach wien
und euch sehen und ich denke das wird
eine ganz tolle messe es wird also ich
denke ja ich freue mich da schon richtig
drauf und was gibt es zu sehen also ich
werde wahrscheinlich nicht so wie bei
den anderen messen dastehen und stunde
lang kochen und backen
das geht nicht wir haben dann einfach
jemanden mit dabei wir sind ja wieder
mal so mit dem kennwort stand zusammen
weil ich brauche immer jemanden der
halten entstand aufbaut und da hab ich
mich jetzt wieder für kennwort
entschieden weil wir dann einfach kochen
und backen können und dann habt ihr auch
was zum probieren und können dann
wirklich live mit dabei sein und da
gibt's dann aber auch den christian mit
dabei der hessischen koch von canon wird
der wird dann auch ein bisschen was
kochen um mich einfach zu entlasten weil
mir das ansonsten zu viel wird aber ich
bin auf jeden fall mit dabei morath ist
dabei mein team ist nicht dabei völlig
risikolos und nicole stocker werke
schnitt dabei ist sie zeigt euch so ein
bisschen was mit von dor und modelle
schokolade und dekoriert da so ein paar
tropfen dummies und ich bin dann einfach
für euch da wie viel ich jetzt kochen
werde packen werde ob ich was koche oder
so weit und so weiter weiß ich jetzt
noch nicht ich habe es auf jeden fall
vor
versprechen kann ich nicht aber ich
werde auf jeden fall da sein
und vom lokal songs haben mit pausen und
hab dann einfach zeit für euch und dann
kann man sich einfach ein bisschen
unterhalten und ich denke das wird ganz
schön und ihr habt wahrscheinlich alle
verständnis dafür dass ich halt nicht so
viele widerstände
ja es gibt viele andere stände da kann
man dann auch in es gibt workshops
es gibt wieder die schotten wettbewerber
aber ich habe da schon einige videos
dazu gemacht natürlich gibt es auch beim
torten wettbewerb wieder gewinnen und
zwar wieder an der kenwood maschine die
wir sponsern
und das ist dann der hauptpreis und ja
apropos gewinnen die es war ja von
depotbanken gewinnspiel und da hat ja
die ich habe es ja noch aber jeweils das
hier aus aus aus paderborn hat ja jemand
die zwei karten gewonnen mit zweimal
hotelübernachtungen ganz peinlich aber
auf jeden fall freue mich darauf dich
dann zu treffen und so wird halt die
messe in wien sein und was ich noch habe
und zwar haben wir 50 karten noch für
die messe in dient die würden wir gern
verlosen
und wenn er sowieso vorhat auf die messe
zu kommen oder wenn ihr jetzt behauptet
auf die messe kommen könnt ihr nämlich
einfach kommentare schreiben und zwar
auf youtube auf facebook und auf
instagram und ich werde dann diese 50
verlosen ich mache kein auflösungs video
oder so sondern ich werde euch dann
direkt sondern beschreiben
bei youtube ich halte das problem da
gibt es ja einige nutzer bei denen ich
nicht beantworten kann weil sie keinen
google+ account haben oder so bist du
musst ja beutegut wird es verbleibt bei
google im jahr bei youtube die leute
müssen die abonniert haben oder an
google plus konto haben damit nun
antworten kannst gerne auch vor läuft
bei leuten die fragen etwas genau und
ich kann sie nicht banal sind da kein
partner genau
also dürfen wir gerne bei instagram bei
youtube und bei facebook kommentar
hinterlassen ich würde gerne zwei karten
gewinnen dann würde ich nämlich sagen
verlosen 25 x 2 karten damit ihr nicht
allein kommen müsst und dann werde ich
die verlosung und euch einfach diese
woche direkt anschreiben und euch dann
darum bitten mich privat eben zu
kontaktieren und dann können wir die
karten eben verschicken gewählt nicht
verschickt er nicht verschicken wir
geben sie aber gerne in seiner kasse ab
mit dem namen und dann wenn ihr zur
messe kommt müsste einfach euren namen
sagen da wird es andere liste
eingetragen
genau weil zum verschicken wer es
nämlich zu spielen ja das war eigentlich
so meinen schwangerschafts update beim
nächsten mal würde ich sagen weil ich da
auch auf die frage hatte nach
babyausstattung erstausstattungen
kinderwagen autositz usw
würde ich dann in einem separaten video
machen wir dieses video ist leider jetzt
schon ziemlich lang geworden
und wenn ihr da noch fragen dazu habt
zur erstausstattung und so weiter dann
stellt sie einfach in die kommentare
und ich werde dann denke ich so in zwei
wochen wieder ein update machen weil ich
habe dann immer so lang kann nicht mal
so viele updates machen und dann halte
ich euch einfach auf dem laufenden
ja vielen dank fürs assistieren zwar
besteht zwar eine ehre mit ihr ja gerne
jetzt nochmal nach samira und ich will
jetzt noch was kochen also bis zum
nächsten mal